and I see exchange at the State of the
Union this week when Utah senator Mitt
Romney confronted first term New York
Congressman George Santos Romney telling
Santos he does not belong in Congress
Santos has been caught in a web of
alleged lies about his background since
winning his election in November
he said he says he you know that he
embellished his record look embellishing
is saying you've got an A when you get
an A minus lying is saying you you
graduated from a college you didn't even
attend and he shouldn't be in Congress
and they're going to go through the
process and hopefully get him out
uh but he shouldn't be there and Santos
responded to Romney's criticism
it's not the first time in history that
I've been told to shut up and go to the
background especially by people who come
from a privileged background uh and it's
not going to be the last and I'm never
going to shut up and go to the back of
the room and I think it's reprehensible
that the senator would say such a thing
to me in the demeaning way he said it
wasn't very Mormon of him that's what I
can tell you
I'm not under any ethics investigation
in that same exchange where the reporter
Santos did not answer about whether his
mother was in the World Trade Center on
9 11. that alleged falsehood falsehood
is one of many Santos is accused of
telling voters Santos's rise to Congress
and the controversy following his
election is the subject of a new
documentary by CBS reports in campaign
of Deceit Caitlin Huey Burns tracked
through Santos's past to try to find
some answers she is here with more
Caitlyn good morning good morning Jeff
well we traveled throughout Santos's
District on New York's Long Island
speaking to constituents political
insiders journalists and even
acquaintances and we even visited Brazil
where Santos once lived but often times
even when we found some answers they
often led to more questions
Congressman do you have a response to
New York we're still calling for you to
step down since the 34 year olds
Congressional win many of the stories
Santos told on the campaign Trail have
been exposed as outright lies you have
more Republicans from New York Brazil
asking you to step down
George Anthony devalder Santos never
worked at Citigroup he was not worth a
hundred million dollars when he was 30.
we don't know for sure but he probably
wasn't a preferred buyer at Hermes he
didn't attend the Horace Mann school his
mother wasn't in the World Trade Center
on 9 11. he wasn't the descendant of
Holocaust Survivors he never went to
Baruch College and George Santos never
won a volleyball championship
really who he is he's a fraud Grant
Lally runs the North Shore leader the
newspaper that during Santos's campaign
published what was otherwise discussed
only in Whispers in Republican circles
she began to be known as George scantos
among those who paid attention George
scantos correct my old campaign manager
called me up out of the blue in the
middle of this campaign and he said
Grant what is this this is not a
campaign this is a beach party on hotels
in Florida alone Santos's campaign spent
more than 11 thousand dollars part of
the more than three million dollars his
campaign spent during his run we know
from his 2020 filings he didn't have any
money at all and then all of a sudden in
2022 he claims to have come into a lot
of money yeah I mean that that was
really the the moment that that really
hit us that there's really something
wrong here was when his campaign Finance
filings claimed that he made a seven
hundred thousand dollar loan to his
campaign prosecutors at the Fed federal
state and local level are now
investigating a watchdog group filed
this complaint with the Federal Election
Commission questioning Santos's expenses
and the source of the funds he loaned
his campaign around the time he loaned
that money Santos was doing this
Harbor City capital before it was
alleged to be a classic Ponzi scheme and
shut down by the Securities and Exchange
Commission George Santos was the
regional director in New York he has
said he wasn't aware of any wrongdoing
after the federal prosecutors shut down
Harbor City capital Santos to form new
companies together with Nancy marks down
in Florida Nancy marks who is she she
was Santos's campaign Treasurer she
filed all of his reports which means she
should have known whether they were true
or false when she filed them as the
treasurer and she had that legal
responsibility hi Nancy we reached out
to Nancy Mark several times and never
heard back
so we showed up at a meeting for a Long
Island library where she serves as a
board member
when we arrived her seat was empty
so we knocked on the door where she runs
her business
the lights were on inside the political
posters hung in the windows but nobody
came to the door
George Santos didn't lie only while
running for congress we crisscrossed New
York City and Long Island digging into
his past and found a trail of bitterness
women and men once close to Santos who
say they'd been burned by his falsehoods
and betrayals
Caitlyn as we saw there welcome first of
all great to see you thank you good to
see you too as we saw there you tracked
down a lot of leads what what else did
you learn about George Santos well we
know what's been out there and what
we've been reporting but we talked to
people who knew him and one compelling
character was a woman who went to middle
school with George Santos and she said
that he exhibited these characteristics
from a young age that he would
exaggerate fabricate to try to fit in
that he was bullied as a child and tried
to kind of try to fit in with these
groups and she sees a lot of parallels
between the person she saw then and the
person she sees now I know you reached
out to him he declined comment but I
mean what what does he say about this
mountain of evidence against him well I
do want to make clear we have tried
multiple times to ask him for an
interview and he declined we caught up
with him in the basement of the Capitol
last week to ask him more questions as
you can see and he wasn't responding to
our questions but here's the thing he
has said he is sorry for fabricating
getting parts of his resume but it is
much more than that he said that his
mother was in the towers on 9 11 when
she wasn't he claimed his parents were
Holocaust Survivors and when we talked
to people in the district those are the
kinds of things that really hit them
because everybody in his district has a
connection to 911 for example and it
just was kind of became personal and
Caitlin we know quickly here there's
calls for him to resign but is there any
recourse because it doesn't seem like
he's going to resign here's the really
interesting thing you can't recall your
member of Congress and as much as his
constituents want him to resign they
came to DC this week to try to force him
out unless leadership moves and and they
won't they want the investigations to
play out and that's something to really
keep an eye on here but for voters those
are the people who are really
disadvantaged in this just have to vote
amount thank you Caitlin and you can
stream campaign of Deceit tomorrow night
at eight Eastern on the CBS News app